i'm pleased to be joined by the leader
of the legal democrats sir ed davey
sarah thank you so much for being with
us let's just pick up on the weather
conditions that we are facing there are
calls um by tim farren for water bosses
to have their bonuses capped until they
fix leaks is that something that you
would be backing totally i think the
water companies have got away with blue
murder frankly they've been making huge
profits
the bosses have been getting uh massive
bonuses and not only have we not
prepared properly for this drought
seeing pollution in our rivers and lakes
which is killing wildlife so on all
accounts they've been failing our
country
and we need some tough measures on them
so how long would this ban on their
bonuses go on for because some of these
companies are saying they can't get a
handle on the leaks until at least 2050.
we're going to just stop the companies
giving up bonuses up until then i think
we need to review the whole way they
have been operating
and we can do that relatively
quickly over the next year or so
but we've got to tackle the problem
they've been allowing these leaks to
continue for far too long
we've seen a waste of water when we're
desperately in need of water for people
there are drought conditions uh and we
need action and i think tim ferran is
quite right to oppose that so do you
think that this uh supports the argument
then that some are making to bring water
companies back into public ownership
well i think we need tough regulation
and there's just not been that
regulation uh there and we've seen that
allow them to remain private or come
back into public ownership well i think
we can do keep uh the current status but
we need tougher regulations that's what
democrats have argued for a long time
and that's regulations both in terms of
sorting out this water shortage but also
the pollution that we've seen in our
rivers we've been allowing these water
companies to pump their filthy sewage
into our rivers liberal democrats in
parliament have put forward uh draft
laws to stop that and unfortunately
conservative mps have voted against that
so conservatives are allowing the water
companies to get away with their
pollution and their failure to act for
our country let's move on now to the uh
cost of living crisis and the
the huge bills that people are facing
you're calling now for there to be a cap
on the prices and for the price cap not
to rise as it will do on the 26th of
august why are you calling for that
right now
i'm very worried about what millions of
families and pensions are going to face
this
winter
and i've been listening to the
conservative candidates for the next
prime minister for a plan
to tackle this to help people but
they've got no plan whatsoever it's
almost like they're living in a parallel
universe so liberal democrats today are
putting forward
our plan and what we're saying is the
expected rise of 1
400 pounds in the energy price cap on
top of the 700 pounds rise last april
we're saying that new rice should not
happen it should be cancelled and it
should be the government that pays
the suppliers
to make sure that people get the
electricity and gas that they need if we
don't do this we're facing a social
crisis a catastrophe
i think from the evidence we've seen in
the democrats we could
be seeing people going hungry uh not
eating as much
turning off their heating and not
heating their homes so if we're going to
avoid a cold hungry winter for millions
of people we have to have the bold plan
that the democrats are arguing for yeah
we know the danger that people are
facing but i wonder how is this going to
be paid for because this is not going to
be cheap for the government to
essentially step in and control prices
yeah there needs to be a big measure
from the government we're saying there
should be a one-off tax on the oil and
gas companies who are making
tens of billions of pounds in profit
profit they didn't expect to make
because no one expected oil and gas
prices to be as high as they are
and i think it's only fair that we asked
those oil and gas companies to pay
some of their profit
to the government so the government
could then help millions of families and
pensioners that's a fair approach it
would also by the way prevent this
catastrophe which is our country is
heading towards you call it one off tax
so is this the same as the windfall tax
that the chancellor yeah it it it's a
winful test but the chancellor's
approach was very weak uh it didn't
raise anywhere near enough money um it
didn't ensure that um uh some of the
profits they've made over this period uh
faced this tax um and they had lots of
loopholes they uh they were given um we
need a proper uh tax on the profits of
the oil and gas companies we've got a
well thought through proposal and it
would pay the large bulk of this idea of
stopping at the energy price cap rising
in october we've got to help people
i think there's huge anxiety out there
people already
cutting back because of the high price
of energy
now
and with energy prices as high as they
are now the idea that they could go up
by another
400 pounds it's frightening to many
people so we need a plan the democrats
are putting on forward so this is a new
windfall tax so you completely redo the
winful taxes already put in place and
yeah because
you describe them as loopholes but the
the chancellor said that they are
incentives to encourage these companies
to continue investing uh in the energy
supply of this country well before he
put forward his plan when liberal
democrats were arguing for this one-off
tax on oil and gas company profits uh
the chief's active bp said with such a
windfall tax they still continue to
invest let's remember the whole point
about this one-off tax are these are
profits that they didn't expect to make
they weren't in their business plan so
they'll go ahead with investments
regardless of this tax and as you know
there is a growing movement don't pay uk
for people not to pay the energy bills
that are coming on the 1st of october do
you support that idea no i don't but i
want the government to take the bold
measures that liberal democrats are now
arguing for if the government took up
the liberal democrat call for cancelling
the rise in the energy price cap
then there'd be no need for that sort of
campaign and we could deliver the help
that millions of people desperately need
we've seen from the evidence from the
polls
uh many people are already saying
they're
not going to eat as much
many people are saying they're not going
to turn on the heating at all
um that is a frightening prospect i
think we're going to see a social crisis
the like we've never seen so we need a
plan and what has been quite
outrageous frankly is whether it's from
the current prime minister or the two
conservative candidates to be the next
prime minister we've had no plan
whatsoever
the energy price right has been like the
elephant in the room uh they've not been
addressed been addressing it in any
coherent way and we can't have a prime
minister living in a parallel universe
we need people
facing up to the reality that millions
of of our citizens face that's why we
need the plan that liberal democrats are
proposing today so do you support the
idea of the two candidates and the prime
minister sitting down before we get the
price rise in the 26th of august to have
a plan in place yeah i i believe we
should have a recall of parliament i
think it should be emergency budget
and what i'm saying beyond that and no
one else has said this
this is the plan for the budget
so we're saying that emergency budget
which should come as soon as possible
should have as a core of its plan
cancelling the rise in the energy prices
this october